tropicana palms offers retirement living
at its finest we paid them a visit
to get a closer look at this amazing
55-plus community
this is tropicana palms
here at tropicana palms residents don't
move here to retire
they come here to live now i can tell
you all about this beautiful community
or we can go inside and talk to linda
the sales manager who not only works
here
but she lives here come on
linda jc it is so good to see you oh it
is good to see you
first things first how has tropicana
palms been handling the pandemic
we have been doing great we have been
open during covid
but safety first masks and social
distance
we are offering self-guided tours for
people's comfort as well as some guided
tours but with social distance okay i
love the fact that you put safety first
and i'm in love with this kitchen tell
me more about this kitchen
this is one of the gems of our
collection i love this home the
beautiful wood plank floor
the large farm sink
this island where you can enjoy
breakfast which is absolutely lovely
and then of course a large walk-in
pantry
everybody loves this this pantry it's
like an extra bedroom it's so big
well for somebody your size all right so
linda you guys make it so easy for your
future residents
to move in what are you guys doing right
now uh we we have
a finance partner that we work with you
we've got
wonderful programs right now i've got a
five thousand dollar down
i've got a special for veterans they're
all kind of things that we do
and it all handled here is smooth it's
kind of a very smooth process
you're looking out for your residence i
love it can you give us a tour of the
rest of this home oh i would love to
after you
we've carried the wood floors throughout
the remainder of
um the main living part of the home of
course you have to have a large laundry
room
and then we have three bedrooms
which is great too because you have
family to come visit you you have extra
space and also maybe
a man cave or man cave or an office
you've got a second full
bathroom that is very convenient to the
bedrooms
and of course the master suite it's a
big master bedroom back here
yes it is with crown molding but the gem
is the master bath and you have his and
her sinks in there what else you have in
there his and her sinks
walk-in shower with a bench plenty of
drawers and cabinets
it is gorgeous thank you so much linda
for showing us the place i love
spending time with you but i do have one
question
uh-oh what did you bring the golf cart
yes
can i take it for a second short ride is
it out front yes it is
see ya linda gotta go
[Music]
i love linda call calam properties
tropicana palms at 702-456-5823 find
them online the address is on your
screen and remember
no payments until 2021 and only
5 000 down on a new home rocky
jc you are such a troublemaker what are
we going to do with you she is so much
more i love her so much she's the best
they're cool over there all right